welcome everyone to our first remote PI
data Amburg meetup and Christian I'm a
freelance data scientist and I'm really
new as an organizer at pilot a Hamburg
it's my first time organizing this I can
tell he has been a couple of challenges
in the last week's but I'm so glad to
see you all here and also glad to share
the hosting duties with Camilla Camilla
you ought to introduce yourself hi hello
everyone my name is Camilla I'm working
it my years work as an IT consultant
very happy to be here tonight and as
Christian mentioned pretty excited
trying to host this virtual meetup in
times of corona and we had so many
change so I'm very glad it work and then
that we are all here tonight yeah thank
you all for keeping community going
these days and also thank you a lot to
the two speakers that are going to be on
tonight maybe before we get started some
information we are recording this and we
want to share this recording on the PI
data YouTube channel later for the
entire world so just know that if you
don't want your picture to be taken then
disable your camera and we hope that
you're going to participate actively in
the Q&A sessions but just keep in mind
that if you do then your voice is going
to be on the Internet
and guy is very important so as you can
imagine it's quite a challenge to manage
a lot of people in this chat so trying
to make it a little bit organized in any
case we are going to be monitoring here
they chat so if you click on
participants you can see the people here
and also yourself at any time you can go
on your right side and just click if you
want I speak you just raise your hand
and then the hosts are going to be
moderating that and we can give the word
for you so just raise the hand just have
to click here and also if you have any
feedback any questions just write it on
the chat please so what did the poll
result say how many new people do we
have here for the first time for a pilot
and so I think someone said well I I
actually mess it up but someone said it
was 67% of new people at least that's
what I saw on the chat so yes that's
great so you may wonder what pioneer is
paella is a global community for
developers and users of open source data
tools so everything open source and data
analysis is in scope and of course we
focus heavily on tools that are written
in the Python language and
organizationally PI data is an
educational program of the Namco's
organization in the US but it's a very
global community with local chapters and
meetups all over the world including
Hamburg
so we would like to start with a call
for participation in this community
about participation and we are still
looking for speakers throughout the year
if you're building anything interesting
with open source data tools or building
these tools yourself then talk to us and
maybe speak about what you're doing and
we want to especially encourage speakers
from underrepresented groups and of
course first time potato speakers and we
want to provide you some support with
preparing your very first pie data talk
then in the in the organizing crew we
could use a few more helping hands so if
you feel like helping us with meetup
planning outreach to speakers and
supporting speakers you're very welcome
please talk to us and last but not least
we're looking for sponsors so if you
could in the future host the meetup at
your venue then there's the opportunity
to win some open-source Karma so this is
our idea and this is what it would be
the next overview from our meetups so we
are now having this virtual one in March
and the idea is that every two months is
we are hosting an event so of course
again as Christian said if you would
like to talk if you could sponsor again
you helped each organize please just get
in touch with us
this would be fantastic the more the
merrier and it really helps to make the
community grow and be very active so for
our agenda our first talk is about
machine learnings with and beddings
and the idea is that we would have a
break around seven five and two seven
twenty we are going to check how it goes
with the talk and with the questions at
this moment we are going to leave
the room open right Christian for for
chats but still people are able to
interact and so on just to have those
questions but we are not going to be
that as I said it's a break then we go
for our next talk it's explaining deep
neural networks using surrogate models
and after that we are going to try out
some networking and this is a really
cool feature here it's not because it's
virtual that it doesn't need to be you
know interactive and at 8:20 we're also
going to have open mic so if anyone in
the community would like to voice
something to know like just have a
conversation 8:20 is the time we are
going to try to stick as much as
possible to this schedule but we asked
the flexibility of everyone as the first
time we are moderating this here with 38
people now so let's see how how it goes
very good all right then it's my
pleasure to introduce Maria our first
speaker who is going to talk to us about
machine learning with embeddings Maria
is a software and data engineer and a
consultant and now it's your chance to
try out the virtual applause button that
you have in the reactions like Camila is
doing right now so if you just go to if
you want to react just clap your hands
you can go here on the reactions and
just click whatever it's alright Maria
so hello everyone and Saints Christian
for the lovely introduction I am super
excited about this great turnout despite
all all things happening around it is
nice to see people interested in data
and machine learning and it was also
warms my heart because that's where data
is for me so all so then let's talk
about it as Christian said I am Maria I
am IT consultant from Berlin
that's also from where I'm calling right
now so hello to everyone in Hamburg or
from wherever you are tuning in I have a
specialization in basically everything
around data and also writing fake horses
but let's go to our today's topic how to
represent text and images in machine
learning since computers are rather easy
they do not understand the concepts
behind text to images so they do not
understand then the word horse means
this foal act animal with a tail and the
mane or that certain amount of pixels
actually depict a horse that is why for
machine learning we need to find a way
to represent text images in such a way
that their meaning is preserved and this
is where embeddings come in place and
today we are going to talk about how to
visualize text and image in bearings we
are going to talk about vertex bedding
specifically about their trick painting
process and also the limitations and
extensions of the currently existing
algorithms for training work in bearings
embeddings and as a general concept of
machine learning help us represent
discrete variables as vectors in the
multi-dimensional space and when I say
discrete variables basically we can
train embeddings for everything we can
train embeddings for images for texts
for movies and books and represent
everything of those things in an
embedded space one thing that is great
about in bearings is that they help to
reduce the dimensionality of foreign
bearings sorry of the object themselves
so let's say we have an image of 1000
times 1000 pixels if we would want to
represent the image as it is for our
machine learning algorithm we would end
up with a vector of 1 million items but
having trained and embedding for this
image the embedding itself would only be
maybe 30 to 100 dimensions so using
embeddings and machine learning also
helps avoid sparse data and additional
computational costs and one of the most
important advantages of Furth embeddings
is that they help represent similar
objects again so they have to represent
objects in such a way that similar
objects end up close together in the
embedded space so let's say we have this
is our embedded space and here's the
d-word horse and the word animal would
be somewhere near and close to it
because horses are a subset of animals
visualizing embeddings here what you can
see are images of handwritten digits so
what happened is we have for each of
these images we have trained
a word embedding and then we have
projected this word this embedding not
word embedding um then we have projected
this embedding into a two dimensional
space for simplicity and digits that
same digits basically cluster together
in the top right we can see a cluster of
once in red and the top left we can see
a cluster of zeros and in the middle we
can see two clusters of nine and force
so let's zoom in a little here you see
in green a four which looks exactly like
the nines around it so even I as a human
would say that those are completely same
digits same happens for the three
tonight think about it again similar
objects similar images end up close
together in an embedding space but
images is not the only thing we can
embed and in an embedding space we can
also embed entire book text and in this
example we can see books entire book
texts even in each point in the graphic
represents an entire book text
so here in embeddings were trained for
entire books and but the colors that you
can see here were added afterwards so
they colors had nothing to do with the
training and the colors represent genres
of books so in the top on the top we can
see thee non-fictional genre here is
your fiction and even a little bit more
down we can see the child no longer and
we see that again books of the same
genre were clustered together so
embeddings that we learned learning -
which book texts are similar and which
are not so what we can do with it let's
say we have a new book and we don't know
the genre for it so we could actually
calculate the embedding for the entire
book text and guess the genre of this
book by the nearest neighbors of this
embedding that we just trained in the
embedding space and if let's say five
nearest neighbors are all of the fantasy
genre then also all book is from the
fantasy genre and my favorite example
are word embeddings that's why I also
keep confusing embeddings and important
bearings so here again we see a gray
graphic where each point represents a
word and the birds that are written out
are the ones that are closest to the
word Queen so a little birds and
princess and royal and King are all
similar to the word king and this is
quite an amazing thing because finding
out what images are similar to each
other might not be as impressive as
actually finding that Elizabeth has
something to do with the word Queen
so
now I would like to come to a short live
demo and before I get into a training
process of word embeddings I want to
show you what effect training data has
on the result of the embedding for this
we are going to use the project tender
flow tool which basically helps us
visualize embeddings in a two or three
dimensional space so we can actually
touch them so let's take a look I scroll
in a little bit so here again we can see
each point in our space is a bird this
data set was trained on Wikipedia
articles and we can select basically any
point and check what it looks like so
here I have the word healing and the
closes first to its closest words to it
can be seen on the right so we have
spells magical runes alchemy cure
spiritual healing and medicine okay
I wonder what Wikipedia articles this
those were let's select another example
failures oh the most similar words are
failure success problems losses
limitation arrows what else we can do is
we can search for certain words so let's
take a look at the word doctor the
nearest neighbors for the word doctor in
here a master degree
doctors physician professor bachelor the
our teacher patient medical and this is
the fascinating thing because
by looking at the most closest word to
the bird doctor we see that the
embedding combines the two domains of
the word doctor together so we see the
medical domain on one hand because we
see the words say like physician and
medical and they see the scientific
domain where we can see the words master
and degree and professor and what else
can can we see we can see that synonyms
also end up close together in the
embedding space maybe I can find a word
which is a synonym public public looks
good
you
well also works for public we have
private government commercial foreign
media military maybe we have let's look
for the one run
Varane we have running runs ran operate
home drive compete live so again we see
close words to it are the synonyms
sometimes but also sometimes
syntactically similar things like the
word was some certain suffix of prefix
and now let's take a look at the
different data set
[Music]
here we I have selected pre-selected the
word kit so the closest to it Amen boy
child makes sense girl but let's look
take a look at the word doctor and maybe
you'll see what data set we've been
training this embeddings on so the
closest words through a doctor a
brigadier TARDIS man monk
as you might have guessed this burden
these word embeddings were trained on
the data set about encyclopedia articles
about Doctor Who but also on the
Wikipedia so encyclopedia about Star
Wars so we'll if we would look for the
word look we will see that the closest
words to look Anakin
Leah Kenobi Ben Vader which is
fascinating so that was a short demo and
this one leads us to another cool
feature that we can do in boredom
barracks namely we can do arithmetic s--
back to our automatics on Burton
bearings here you can see three vectors
for the words King men and woman so what
happens if we would take the vector King
and subtract the vector men from it we
would end up with this vector and then
we want to add the word woman to the
king - men this is that's gonna be this
spectra and maybe some of you could
guess it the outcome of this arithmetic
is the vector ax for the word Queen
which is an amazing amazing feature so
we can see we have the same relations
for from King to men as we have from
Queen to women so the semantics of the
words is preserved in the vector space
helping the algorithms that we will use
to probe which we will use the word
embeddings kind of understand what the
actual words mean because the vectors
will combine the meaning in terms of
synonyms in terms of relations between
each other which is amazing
and I've talked a lot about similarity
today but what actually similarity means
here you can see a quote by the famous
by a famous linguist John Rupert first
who said that you shall know a word by
the company it keeps so what does it
mean it means that the word are
considered similar if they appear in the
similar context so what does that mean
again let's take a look at these
sentence I drink coffee with milk and
sugar also I don't do that but maybe
someone go
so I drink coffee with milk and sugar
the word coffee appears in the context
of the words I drink and this milk and
sugar and we have another sentence like
I drink tea with milk and sugar then the
both words coffee and tea appear in the
same context which would lead to those
words being similar which makes sense
so how do we train the word embeddings
and the entire entire research about
training virgin weddings is rather new
so people come up with similar
approaches that result in almost the
same the same so one approach for
training word embeddings is called
continuous pack of words and the other
is skip gram those are only two out of a
lot more because the Royal research just
keeps going new approaches emerge every
not every day but and they emerge
so continuous pack of words continuous
pack of words tries to take a look at
the surrounding of our word and tries to
predict the word from its surroundings
so let's say we have the words I drink
with milk and we have the word in the
middle that is masked so we will try to
from the words I drink and with milk we
will try try to predict the words tea
and coffee and
then we will have based on our input we
will have a layer of projection
and
our neuronal network what it can do it
can basically select the embeddings in
the middle so it can select how it will
set the projection layer so what values
to give to it however we have a lot of
data to that we feed into our neuronal
neuron no no net so it can't remember if
that if the words I drink and with milk
appear that it should method to tea and
coffee
so the neuronal network is forced to
generalize and by generalizing it needs
to map the projection there in such a
way that the same context leads to
similar or similar context leads to
similar output values in such a way that
the embeddings for coffee and tea would
be similar
and what I have not told you that the
interpreter is that the entire process
is unsupervised so basically we have a
huge set of articles of written text
data and we feed this entire thing in TD
algorism sentence after sentence and
while iterating through the sentence we
will try to predict from the surrounding
to predict the word in the middle and
skip gram is an approach that takes that
works similar but takes a completely
reversed approach so here we will try to
predict the surrounding of a word so the
context of a word from the word in our
example we will try to predict the words
I drink with milk from the words coffee
and tea
and this is basically how the training
process works
unfortunately this procedure has a
limitation so this approach has a
limitation basically if we have a given
training set and we haven't seen and the
training set doesn't contain all the
words that are possible and a lot of
words are possible in this world then we
will have words that appear only in the
test set but not in the training set
those words are called
out of vocabulary words and those out of
vocabulary words would have no proper
representation in our algorithm because
all out of vocabulary words would be
mapped to a vector of zeroes so if we
haven't seen the word look in our
original training data the word look
would be exactly the same as the word
horse if we haven't seen horse which is
a problem for training because out of
vocabulary words lose lose meaning and
here Facebook came up with a quite nice
idea they called the approach fast text
and the idea behind it is to represent
each word is a bag of character engrams
what does it mean character engrams
means basically a subset of characters
let's take a look at an example the word
sunrise and the end for us is 4 so if it
would split the word sunrise in a subset
of 4 characters we will get this so we
had get sunburned hungry Norris and rice
but
as I said it's just a back of character
engrams
so they do not have order and to help so
where the back we would not be able to
differentiate where it is the beginning
of the world and where is the end that
is why we introduced two additional
characters to mark the beginning of the
end of the world so we have two
additional
you
Ingram's
one being the beginning of the world and
Sun and the other being
ice and the end of the world
and with this we get
can get a vector for the word sunrise
that was not seen in the training data
by combining the embeddings for the
engrams and combining the Sun and the
rice would actually give us a meaningful
representation for the word sunrise
which is nice and another advantage is
that this approach also helps to correct
misspellings because if someone would
spell the word differently it would not
be an issue because all the other end
grubs would still make up for it and
that is
newest of the newest but that is the
research around the world embeddings
right now
and that also concludes my talk if you
guys have questions now is the time I
probably go I don't know if I should
stop sharing maybe I'll stop sharing for
a second thank you so much so for the
Q&A session do you want to take
questions yes please we had one we have
one question here I'm going to honor it
the first one okay
Arne
no I just grabbed Oh one is the Clemson
law okay we expect before if you want to
ask a question to Maria then you should
use the function of zoom that is raising
your hand you can clap but you can also
raise your hand in the menu and then we
are going to take questions at unmute
your microphone or if you want you can
also just right here on the chat so
there was a question before from nism
there is one here on the chat do you
provide an example code on github
yeah Melina um I have example code on
github I will post a link and D channel
um the example code for it is not the
training part for word embeddings but it
is the actual using it to classify the
data so because also most of the times
the objective is not always to train
your own version bearings because that
would mean to reinvent the wheel most of
the times people just reuse give
inverted bearings
that's why also the example focuses on
classification with Vardon bearings but
yeah I'll provide a link there was
before a question from Nisa and it was
what this star represents star mm-hmm I
think it was in the middle of your talk
right was right on the beginning time I
go through the slides so Nissan is still
here with us in case yes maybe would
like to just ask directly
[Music]
in the book Jared that's the this star
in the book genre I'll share my slides
again then it's easier to understand so
thanks again and here are the slides
let's present fantastic let's go to the
book genre I don't think the star has a
particular meaning but I need to ah the
stars just make that the points are
easier to to see so we have some
examples here an example of encyclopedia
britannica and the style makes that
easier to see where the Encyclopedia
Britannica is in the entire in the
entire embedding space and currently is
the question about the code I have
realized I have forgot slide I have
forgotten slides
here is the example code so take a
screenshot maybe but I can also post it
later and this ended chat any more
questions anyone before we go for a
break
you
oh yeah this is a good question so the
question is for some of the examples it
looks like the word gets mapped close to
the cinemas as well as the opposites
this is true because often synonyms and
antonyms they do appear in the same
context and this and this idea of the
context is also the driving idea so
there is not always a solution to work
around it because that's the entire idea
that we take the context and this is
probably also a disadvantage of the
entire approach if that answers your
question
and here is the link to D it have purple
so the question is if we can run any
pre-processing on the text yes and
pre-processing of them helps to
definitely reduce the space the limiters
ation helps to slim down just to the
root of the word but often Reapers
pre-processing can be also often a
disadvantage because let's say the
pre-processing removes the
capitalization and they have the word
apple which is just a fruit and we have
the word Apple written with a caped
capital A then if we actually leave the
capitalization in we would train two
different word embeddings for the two
different words and there would be less
confusion between the two entities so we
would not confuse we will not confuse I
got distracted by chat we will not
confuse the fruit with the company
so to round up the question it
definitely depends on the use case if we
want to use pre-processing or not so
sometimes it's really beneficial
sometimes it can also do some harm
mm-hmm next question is what NLP project
I am working on currently so currently I
don't have a NLP project but the
previous one was about that's where I'm
you sort embeddings to classify customer
incoming email emails so basically to
say if this customer if this email
reaches the customer support to classify
to where it goes if it goes to the
complain or a question or whatever
category
and the next question is did you apply
the word embeddings for an actual use
case how successful was it okay so that
was my use case and how successful was
it it was so first I tried with more
conventional method so SVM and you know
forget it has nothing to do business
vamps so it was super successful for our
use case we had used Burton pairings to
classify the emails and we had around 30
categories and the accuracy was around
85 to 87 percent which for seven
categories is a high is a high accuracy
and I have used the fast X approach for
it okay are there any more questions
any more questions maybe via audio no
raise hands I guess not
thanks again Maria thank you so much for
listening
then I'll unmute myself and see myself
out
and we're going to 15 minutes break for
everyone and see you in a while so if
you have any technical questions about
how to use zoom feel free to ask them in
the chat and we'll be happy to in you in
50 minutes
you
hello everyone we're about to start
again let's give people a minute to come
back from the break
so welcome back and now it's my pleasure
to introduce Oliver for our next talk on
explaining deep neural networks using
surrogate models Oliver as a software
developer and of Software Architect and
books also is a data scientist and now
the stage is yours Oliver thank you so
much know where the applause button is
yeah it's strange to just speak into the
silence of it all so um let's see if I
can share my screen here okay should be
cool you see the notebook
you
we yes we do cool ok so I need to move
something to the left here so this talk
is about explaining deep neural networks
using surrogate models this is the link
to the notebook I posted it into the
chat already so he want to follow along
just click on this thing this is me or I
mean this was me two years ago I see
because of different glasses now but I
pretty much look the same sometimes just
for the fun of it aware this this the
snap code justice issue people this is
actually well something like experiments
but it's a bit doggy people aren't
typically they're alienated by it so it
works really well so okay what are we
doing today so why are we talking about
explain ability and as a short
motivation I would like to hear from you
people um why would you think that
explain ability um a matter so what are
you you're what are you takes on it I
have some stuff but maybe you have some
ideas so what could be a good reason to
have explain ability somewhere why would
it be interesting to understand why your
model makes the decision it actually
makes and he take us could be on shared
you just raise your hand if you ask the
question
anyone they'll be shy
nothing
disappointing our responses coming in a
chat Oh in the chance show a rhythm for
example legal issues are attributing in
these decisions oh that's good
legal issues right so let's just I had
promised seen the chat so let's see so
we have legal issues
well can you wheel for me Christian
because I was a second one is
attributing the decisions oh yeah do it
what else third one is understanding how
and why decisions are made could help us
all with something like debugging maybe
oh why decisions are made absolute model
yeah yes XCOM this to understand which
parts of the features most related oh
okay
which parts of features I related yeah
maybe
oh yes so my mom told me like this I am
rather an engineer so I got into
programming because I had the illusion
of being in control I found out it's
it's not true but it actually knows me
not to understand so people don't like
black boxes and this includes me but
sometimes that's best you don't like
what is good one yes what else oh I mean
that's all so far any more ideas feel
free to use the chat I think that's it
okay cool so let's match it to what I
was thinking so where's my motivation
sorry
so this is the stuff that you came up
with this is the stuff I came up with
that's pretty much the same I think
which is disappointing but also good
because it's not totally absurd so
sometimes you have the right to
explanation it's backed by the gdpr and
even in the US where people always think
it's not the case your credit score
gives you so if you receive a credit
score you have the right to know why
that is your credit score and then same
thing we don't like black boxes explain
ability brings trust um it helps
debugging to see is the model doing
anything reasonable and it might also
help identifying unwanted bias and that
might relate to this thing here which
parts of features are related or what is
the basis of making a decision okay and
some people even say transparency is an
ethical concern so this was a talk by
Richard Soulja from Salesforce at scared
ml 2020 and he said in the middle right
here um transparency is something that
that we really both owe the people
um maybe you're not always agreeing and
especially that's coming from Salesforce
and might be I don't know interesting
but a lot of people care for it so but
what is the challenge so the challenge
here was this thing here so the
challenge is some models are good for
explain ability sorry um like decision
trees for example but they tend to
overfit because that's that's what they
do that's how they are defined another
models like new networks which I really
like very much I like them are they are
black boxes so they're both good and bad
at the same time so that's the challenge
at least I'm facing a lot of times that
brings us to my approach and this don't
get me wrong so there's a link up there
that's and also things down on there too
more theoretical materials not something
I came up with so it's not my idea to
use surrogate models but it's it's it's
an idea that has been around for quite a
long time so I'm just using it and I'm
just showing you what it means and what
it can do
so the approaches you
each decision tree so in the end you
want the decision tree because you want
explain ability and we'll see how this
works but you don't teach it directly
but first you train um on your network
and you train your network because it
helps to fight overfitting in the
decision tree that's might sound strange
but we will look into it so the steps we
are taking it we are taking to do this
and those are the steps in this notebook
so I'm not actually executing it as we
go along I execute it a little bit
before and I hope it will not shut down
it's on Colette but you could execute
each of these steps all the whole
notebook and it would still do the work
for you so first we need to understand
our example then we train a decision
tree or to see how works on that example
then we training your network same data
and then use that at point fee
sorry point for we use the that's the
most important that we use the you
network to generate new data and you
could see this s as a means of
augmenting good data which is not
totally accurate but it's a way of
looking at it and with that new data we
train our the decision tree and see how
that goes and I'm telling you it goes
pretty well and then we will simplify
that decision tree to make it more
explainable but we don't have to so this
gives us a dial between very explainable
but not very accurate or very accurate
but not explained and then as the final
step in step seven we use that um tree
to give us explanations why why are we
making the decisions we are making so
let's get started so we understand our
example first this is the sample data
that abroad and it's it's it's a made-up
example so it's not really real but it
could be real so it's very close to real
example to real use case I was having um
what do we see so we want to classify
risk of car crashes and this is based
on two features I have more features but
since displaying things in 2d makes it
easier and leave it faster also I just
use two features named eh and Max speed
that means on this x-axis here you see
the age of a certain driver that goes
between I think that should be 18 and
this is a hundred I guess and that's the
max speed in miles per hour so there's
not kilometres miles per hour is I think
it's around 1.6 so 100 would be 160
kilometers and each of these points that
you are seeing here um is one of the
samples that we have that's all the
samples that we have and this one here
the red one that is the triangle that
points down this high risk so people in
this area um there's a lot of samples
having high risk this yellow one that
points up the triangle that is medium
risk in this area and the blue ones that
look Becker I don't know a rhombus no if
you say then eh that's lowest so that's
the data line that I'm having and this
is obviously able data and this is a
supervised learning task now I want to
make a prediction um if I see someone I
don't know maybe this one here up here
what's the risk of this drive so first
we need to understand why we cannot just
directly train the decision tree on it
this brings us to step two
so using scikit-learn
I just generate this decision tree
classifier which well it's just plain
vanilla as simple as it gets I train it
on the training data I get an accuracy
of point 96 not too bad unfortunally on
the test data that I'm having so split
the data before like well a lot of
people do I
near sixty percent and you probably know
that this means it's overfitting
because as I keep saying that's what
decision trees - that's how they are we
find there now look at a plot that's a
common clot that unfelt really works in
2d but in 2d it works pretty well and in
the foreground you still see the the
samples but just the test data so just
destined a the fragment not all the data
and in the background you see the
prediction of the decision tree there's
also a little bit of probability in
there that means the darker the color
the higher the certainty of the
prediction according to the decision
tree so this is blue this one here this
is yellow and this is red so this means
this one is low-risk
this is high-risk the red one and this
is medium and I think it goes without
saying that that's a horrible like plot
the decision boundaries they look really
bad it's like Swiss cheese with all the
holes in it and it's just it just
illustrates the large amount of
overfitting that's taking place here so
to be fair you could regularize that
decision tree and it wouldn't look as
bad but on on this data it would be
extremely hard to get some anything that
sits that's reasonably good you could
use when forest or I don't know some
other ensembles to fix that but then it
won't no longer be explainable in so we
have a probably hope that's
understandable up to this point do you
see that we have a problem as I say for
certain reasons maybe I'm not smart
enough I don't see the Chet maybe I did
something wrong I can't see it let me
read to chat to you yes can you ask your
question again
so did so my question
or the people can respond in chat right
perfect so my question is do you get
that we have an issue yes so we want to
have something that's explainable
we have decision trees that might offer
this but if you train the decision tree
on our data that's what we get so do you
see we have a problem
good father says accuracy to know
accuracy of the of the test data that is
is too low but also the spread between
the accuracy of the training data and
the test data that's a real issue
because that also tells us accuracy on
training there very high accuracy on
test data pretty low that's overfitting
so what we you don't want that right so
we want the model to generalize well on
the chat as I said among the question
what I did no good good good perfect so
then I just assume that that is fear
maybe it becomes clear now
so on the flipside so on the other side
we have the new networks and I like them
a lot so this brings us to step 3
why not use new networks that can
generalize really well we could use
different models that also general or
architectures or strategies and also
generalize very well so new networks are
just one example of a model that's a
little bit stronger for generalization
we don't go to the detail of how our
regular ice the model just shortly it's
self regular rising no self normalizing
sorry self normalizing new network
it's pretty much like drop out without
the batch normalization but it's it's I
tried it with a lot of ways of regular
rising whenever
doesn't matter too much so they all work
well so they're not going into the
details of the model if you really
interested you can look at it later we
are looking at let's say for us the
numbers so the training accuracy is 68
and the test accuracy is 69
so it actually shouldn't be higher but
that's met might be due to debt we just
have like not too many sentenced but
let's look at the decision boundaries by
the way if there's a question at any
point I hope you raise your hand and
Christian will see it and um I don't
know do something let's look at this
decision boundaries and I just ran this
like 10 minutes ago so I always see a
slight variation in this in boundaries
but this is actually what I like so
there's not Swiss cheese we just have
let me count one two three four five six
areas the decision boundaries that means
the lines that separate those classes
are really smooth very nice this is what
I like so that's one of the reasons why
I really like in the networks so for me
that's a good result unfortunately this
is a black box so let's see how many
parameters do we have in that model so
it's just the training I need to point
you to the ways it oh yeah so we have
127,000 parameters you might argue that
the model that maybe is a little bit too
complex for the problem and it might be
true but if even if he made it simpler
even if he if he had ten neurons so I
don't know twenty it would simply
extremely hard to see why I mean you a
network does what it does
so that's well it's a black box and even
though I said I don't like black boxes I
like what the black box does so the
question is can have my how you say in
English my PI and eta2 or German
watchmaker my math mind for neatness is
that possible so the answer is yes so
you always need to compromise but the
basic idea that's there
maybe the only pub that's really tricky
to get that tried to make this drawing
here hopefully it makes clearer so what
are we doing now so we are creating a
new data set that we're using for the
training of the decision tree so how do
we do it say those are the decision
boundaries that we had before
more or less I tried my best here but
now we no longer let me screw up we no
longer use the real training that so
we're not using those data points this
and this is this but we using the
prediction of the new network that means
we're using the background map which
again is not my idea so it's it's
something that comes from the from the
area of surrogate models so each of
these black points you know which is not
perfect I have to admit it should be
perfect that's just my drawing each of
these black points now is a new sample
for the training and this gives this the
all new data set different properties
than we had before so they are very
irregular that also means that for each
of these features for age and then for
max speed we have the same number of
different values which is interesting
because it will fix a flaw in decision
trees where where when we don't have
that the the how do you say that that
the estimation which feature adds the
most of the prediction will be flawed if
that's not the case so it's very regular
very nice we have more samples now
because we just I don't know we generate
as many samples as we want that might
also become a problem if you go from 2d
to I don't know nd to 100 e because the
size the sample size will probably large
so it might become a problem but for
this example it's not a problem so it's
it's not too bad and also what we're
describing is the samples now a very
smooth boundaries so it's it's almost
like sampling this this new prediction
space
and like sampling from those smooth
boundaries that's what I also said some
amount of use per feature so this is
what a new network does for us that's
the only really maybe the only new idea
maybe you knew that you could do it but
that's that's a debatable so that was
step four and this brings us to step
five now we use this new data to Train
the decision tree again
so step 5 and maybe I already gave you
surprise here okay I'm doing it now
so this is again in decision tree to see
nothing just plain vanilla decision tree
trained on the newly generated data and
maybe to your surprise so when I first
saw this it was to my surprise I mean
now I'm perfectly recreates that
decision boundary and actually this
decision tree is possible this is able
to have really smooth boundaries that's
by far the best decision boundaries I
ever saw by a decision tree at least me
you would expect something else namely
you would expect something that's looks
much more like boxes okay cool so but
you see so the max depth of this
decision tree unfortunately is 13 if you
plotted that that would mean like a
decision tree of depth 13 so something
pretty big so there might be another
issue but let's have a look at this
course so perfectly matches on the
generated you train data and it does it
because that's what decision trees are
very good at overfitting on the data you
provide them
fortunately the data that we are
providing the decision tree with is so
much generalized already by the new
network but we are still overfitting but
on data there is so general that on
video data it doesn't over fit I will
show
so on the original data the scarf for
the training data's 68 so almost 69 and
for the testator 69 so we're seeing in
no longer with its which we already knew
because it perfectly mimics what on the
network does and that's the trick
so you've trained on something else so
use the new network as the teacher to
have a decision tree that's very much
regularized unfortunately as I said
going back to this max step but that's
too deep so if you want to understand
the decision and you have to go through
13 decisions that is too deep it's
pretty good it's a pretty good model
it's probably about the best model you
get but it's hoody but now you get a
dial between do you want that
explainable or do you want it more
accurate or something in between so I'm
going to extreme here to extremes and
bringing the depth of the decision tree
down to three and I do this by providing
like the typical parameters to the sued
tree to regularize it but this time I
don't want to regularized because I
always are already done this I want it
to be simpler but not to regularize it
to make it more general but to make it
more explainable so I restrict the depth
to three which is really really shallow
and I say I want the maximum of the six
output nodes and six I chose me because
I counted the segment's from the
prediction of the new network which was
also six but this is pretty much
arbitrary you could make it little bit
deeper then it would amount to making
the model more accurate but less
explainable but this is what I chose so
you see max depth is actually three you
see it does not perfectly match the the
generated data anymore but on
on the original training data I get 60
and on the testator I'm even a little
bit better so I'm around 60% now which
is pretty good so if you want to compare
sometimes it's nice at the baseline I
don't have it in here I wrote some rules
by hand but carefully analyzing like
where are the where are the the spots in
this thing and I never got better than
55% so this is already pretty good but
look at the sitting boundaries so i
re-render several times they always look
pretty similar and this is astonishingly
only simple I think and this is also the
reason why it doesn't all fit because
it's so simple and it probably will also
not over fit on some data we've never
seen because again it's so simple so we
see this area down here you see it's
pretty dark in color that means it's
very certain and this is the low-risk
area it's very certain that this is
high-risk area because it's dark red
this is medium risk this is slight red
high-risk area that means it's not
certain but that's it thinks it should
be highest
so now we have something that's much
simpler but we have the hope that we can
understand how it comes to its decisions
obviously it works otherwise I wouldn't
be showing you this but so let's see so
let's use this data for explanation and
there several libraries that can plot a
tree so let's look at the tree that's
generated here and we can interpret this
by hand first of all we don't want to do
this by hand like next time or if he if
he actually all people an explanation
you not always want to look at this by
hand and say ok that's what I'm seeing
what we do it as a first step because we
want to understand understand what's
happening so the first thing here the
first node it asked is the age smaller
than 62 and this is yes and then we're
asking and is it also less than 33 let's
go this way let's say yes maybe and then
it's the speed more than 112 and again
this is in miles per hour that would
mean I don't know maybe that's 180 talk
max speed and if this is yes oh no sorry
is it less than if there is no that
means it is bigger then we come up to
this thing to the high-risk class when
you see it's pretty sure that's highest
now how would we explain this so we
would say okay you are obviously young
so he if he were to explain to the
person who got this ranking we were
saying okay you are young and you cause
fast that means high risk there you go
this makes sense to me but I guess if he
in the sense of gdpr we have to give
someone an explanation it would also
work at least it works for me um let's
have a look on the right side people are
interested much more if they got a bad
score let's see so we also have this
high
over here let's go through this so that
means if you are older than 62 we go on
this area here and then if your car well
it's not really fast but a little bit
faster
not really then you also get high risk
we are not so sure about it we see it by
the color of this thing but we would
still see probably because you live it
older there might be a higher risk of an
accident so that might work as I said
maybe you want to try it on we examples
and get something back it generated some
explanation
let's see you can do that and I'm using
the library d3 this by my friend
Terrence we actually spent some time
like tweak it for me um and what am I
doing this so this is my example so the
example is 100 obviously it's not H so
this should be max speed this should be
the age of the driver and now I want to
see how would the decision tree handle
that case and you stick and stuff into
duty tree with the model the data arms
and some parameters and also that sample
and what you get is this it might look
familiar and also perfectly fits into
the screen was nice it's the same thing
as the tree you saw before but at this
time one of the paths is highlighted
naming this so it's the same tree so
again first split its the person younger
than 62 yes
then is the person older than 33 oh yes
it's older so we end up here then speed
of the car is it below 133 and then we
end up in this area and you see the
distribution of the of the data that was
used to form that area I would say quite
sure what's what's the correct term and
you see we're pretty sure about this
because most people in that area are our
lowest which is this color this
and we also see okay this is the way the
sample took to end up here and I have it
in another section way it spits out with
like just which decision it took I think
that's pretty helpful and also these one
two three four five six are the six leaf
nodes and they represent the six areas
that we score up that we saw in a second
but we saw here - each of these leaf
nodes represents one of those areas and
we ended up in this one so we are very
sure on Sofia's 49 yes 100 so we are
around here so we are pretty sure for
this one get to this decision further
down I have the thing with more features
of three features where this thing no
longer helps because we can't look at it
in more than 2d this is just to
illustrate that it's possible to use the
same approach with with this decision
tree so here is it and the visualization
even if you can't use that decision bomb
and you can have the graphic or you
could have a textural presentation let
me see if I have it yeah that's the
textual representation not entirely sure
if it is very helpful what I also did
more or less for the fun of it i
generated Python code from this and it
looked pretty good I had the survey on
Twitter if the people so I generated in
three different ways which way the
people liked better and no one even like
had a clue that this was not my cold
that it was generated except for one
person who said like the code looks too
good
it can't be by you but other than that
you could also use it to like I don't
know it might be strange way of bringing
this model into production but it could
be just a few lines of Python code that
generated
that decision tree gets regenerated I
did not do this so but I'm not quite
sure if it might be good idea okay so as
I said I'm skipping more or less yeah so
I'm always skipping step eight because
there's a lot of experiments that I did
myself just to give you the idea so
typically we don't want unwanted bias
and we want to know which feature at
which impact on the decision
so we once well some people might even
argue we don't want a decision based on
age because we don't want bias against
age typically it's against religion or
gender or sexual orientation or
what-have-you but we can very easily
have a look at the vita feature
endpoints that was the name was lacking
early on to see which of the parameters
had the largest impact on our results so
we would see ok age pretty much a speed
not so much but we still would know ok
age has an influence if you don't want
that we wouldn't need to I don't know
get rid of it do something for the model
but at least we know age is quite
significant and as I said and the
typical decision tree those feature
importance they are flawed it can be
shown and then there's permutation pawns
and more things but in the way we train
the decision tree they're probably not
flawed because we have the same number
of values for future it's a little bit
hard to explain if you really want to
understand you can click on the link
above but also my friend Terrance
explains why it's flawed but in our case
it's not so it's pretty reliable that
age has a large impact so the rest of
the stuff is rather scary examples sorry
experiments so I'm skipping that and I'm
coming to the summary already
not quite sure if I'm in time but I
think so
so let's sum it up so our approach is to
teach a decision tree using a stronger
model it does not have to be in network
I just happen to like network and those
in your networks they can fight
overfitting like extremely efficient I
like them but it could be I don't know a
support vector machine something maybe
it could even be a random forest what
you like but on the other hand you still
have all the benefits of a decision tree
because you see the network to change
the decision tree and then we get our
future importance we have a good
understanding of how certain we are and
we also can make it clear why we think
that I think as I tried to show in in
the g-wiz part and we have overall
explained ability so that was our
approach so I think is just repeating
the stuff let's see yeah I think that's
that's the same thing I said here just
in different words and with that I would
point you to those things if you want to
know more about surrogate models this
guy pissed off from unity I think that's
great work on interpretability
as a more general topic on there's more
detailed stuff on the topic down in more
experiments this is post I presented it
scared ml but what you have it's helpful
but I thought since I'm having it on
we'll just add it okay I'll move that I
would like to thank you and open it for
questions if there are and again I'm not
quite sure why but I don't see the chat
maybe you have to stop sharing and then
I see it again thanks Oliver there's
already a couple of questions in each
other and I'm just gonna read up to you
that's okay okay please do that
so ava has asked during the talk is the
explain ability issue they're not still
present just now in generation of the
new data points and not any
or in the model if we change the new
network we would get different input
data a question mark
yes so if you change in your network and
if you did different sorts of
regularization we would get different
input data that is true so maybe I don't
get the question maybe if I can be
unmuted and if that's at all possible
let's see if I can answer
maybe if she can repeat the question
later I'm not quite sure what what she's
really asking but its first of all it's
true if you're changing the new one
Network we get different input ID yes
that's true there's a comment or
clarification comment from flex lecture
if I understood it right you generate
data in a grid like fashion for example
equidistant steps that a new network
predict the risk score then train
decision tree on that generated data and
scores I could have done this I'm just
training the decision tree on the
generated data and just the arc max so
just the highest probability so not on
this course I look even sure if I could
have trained in decision tree using this
course but I did not maybe maybe it's a
good idea I wouldn't is a decision tree
able to be trained on this course as
well
Chris yeah we know that I don't know
maybe that's why I didn't do it because
I wasn't she wasn't sure how to do it
but I'm not using so I just use the add
max so the highest probability but other
than that exactly what what whoever that
was different
the next question is from Ben and Ben
asks is there any particular reason for
using a grid instead of the original
points seems like a great risks focusing
training on regions where you have
sparse data also making it difficult to
scale to high dimensions so yes so as I
said it's difficult to scale this to
higher dimensions what what my question
would be what would be the alternative
to using a great
so maybe I'm just not seeing it my or oh
I see original points okay
okay I'm seeing the I'm seeing the Tecna
that's good thing great Ben clarifies he
says why not use the original points so
the point is why we don't we don't use
the original points we use it for the
new network and the new network can
handle that because a new network if you
do the right things is able to
generalize really well but decision
trees by definitions always overfit
that's the problem that's why we are not
using the original points but then it's
alright we buy this for the the Downs
heads that he's he's mentioning and we
using the output values of the new
network yes but maybe he means something
else using the output values of the new
network but oh yeah oh yes so oh yeah I
get that I get that I get that so I
think this is different approach also
described by people using surrogates so
you no longer generate a grid but use
the original points but only like
they're the input and the output of the
of the new network that's also something
that's totally possible with with this
thing we would have I'm reading the the
comments well that's why I'm stop
talking yes so yeah maybe a distribution
also possible and that's also what
people do with this thing I chose the
grid approach
because it gives it fixes the the flow
of the decision tree when we look at the
feature honks but I don't have to UM
someone says you get a line yet lime is
a different approach but now I think I'm
skipping the Q line is a different
approach of explaining things and it is
very well I shouldn't skip the cube so
maybe we should return to the next
question is Christian surrounds its
casino okay
so would you bleed it out for everyone
so that it gives me a good feeling that
people talk to me so John which one was
the next you was there some comments for
example one by Olaf
nice approach I was not aware of this
but in this example the accuracy is very
low so although you can explain this
decision it is only slightly better than
random guessing for example it would put
people many times in the wrong risk
class at least I would not trust it in
real life so all I was saying it's it's
only slightly better than random
guessing I'm very surprised by that
because random guessing would be 33
because we have three classes right and
it had to put people in different or I
had to make black because it's really
blow up like in real life example
unfortunately having something like
almost 60 or 70% is definitely better
than when I'm guessing I mean it's also
question often of how accurate do you
have to be or how what do you need to be
trite if you need as I said beat
handwritten rules which however I tweet
them I didn't get the score close to 60
um it might be good enough but I still I
stood by what else point because if he's
saying if the accuracy is not high
enough I wouldn't use it if six is not
high enough don't use it but as I said
it might be hard to find something
that's better than 70 I guess it's not
it's a little bit hard because Olaf
can't respond or maybe he did oh yeah
all right three classes you're right
as I said it depends on is it good
enough for something to do and I think
that's a would amount to a totally
different talk how good do you have to
be to do something I mean if this was a
self-driving car yeah probably not but
if you're saying well that's better than
anything we had before and also you
always have to live with risk right in
this case what is your risk you could
risk like giving I don't know if you
have a car insurance you would risk
giving them something that's a little
bit better than they should have but I
agree it's always a question of like is
it good enough and I can't answer that
because we don't have a really loose
kissing okay maybe you choose that let's
see what's the direction of the
discussion shall we talk about mine or
is this totally off topic I'm not sure
somebody asked a question so okay the
first question it was good which one was
it
I hope so we all knew to die apologize
we don't know how to do it correctly but
which one I see the chat now that's good
but legal issues yes he's repeated I
think you touched on the shifting they
explain an ability problem from the
model to the data issue already I think
so so maybe if you have more pointers
for me what you want to know and then I
could give more
but if you don't maybe we at least say
one word to Lyme so in the links from
the okay now comes the clarification I'm
sorry the keep jumping back and forth
I'm impatient
you
you
yes so obviously my so the question
again is don't we still have that the
explain plane ability problem obviously
man so was not good because you still
have the question yes the explain the
ability problem is still present um but
we now shift like how would you say the
capacity of the new network and its
ability to generalize we shifted over to
the decision tree world I would say and
we still have the same issue there but
then we have the in decision tree world
we have abilities to simplify the model
to an extent that the model gets so
simple that we can use it for explain
ability and we cannot at least not with
any measure I know do this in neural
network world that's why I'm shifting
the problem over to a decision tree
world where it could be s as good as new
your networks since the new networks
served as the teacher but we can now
choose the dial by restricting the depth
of the tree to get bad explained ability
and trade it for accuracy I didn't show
you the intermediate steps and then you
would have seen that we get anything in
between so Holly would you like to take
any more questions or comments or just
maybe continue the discussion I guess we
should do discussions offline it would
be interesting I'm really interested in
all kinds of feedback you can send me
email um I don't know do something
somewhere I'm not quite sure how we do
it
but if you if you find something
interesting shared with me it's it's I'm
always interested okay so thank you
people